si je ne peux pas je ne peux pas je ne
peux pas le tournage auquel participe
Gérard junio à tour n'a rien d'une
comédie il tourne ici dans l'escalier de
l'Hôtel de Ville le premier épisode d'un
téléfilm où il a le rôle d'un avocat
onouré dans cette mairie avec le drame
qu' a eu récemment à tour c'était
quandme un petit peu un petit peu
bizarre quoi mais oui surtout là ils ont
ils ont pas
lesésiné l'ancienne maie tour c'est é
fait au début du siècle dernier enfin la
fin du siècle dernier ça y a été dans la
solenité dans dans la les ors de la
République c'est assez impressionnant
d'ailleurs mais mais c'est ça fait
partie du c'est un décor l'avocat joue
un rôle il joue une sa partie donc c'est
c'est un un truc de de comédien quoi 80
techniciens et 400 figurants participent
à cette réalisation les figurants sont
tous de la région comme cette fan de
Gérard Jun venu de saint-ciè surloire
j'aime beaucoup Jun et là je suis ravie
de de le voir jouer là bientôt je vois
qu'il a son habit de de maître là à tour
le palais de justice et la mairie ont
été choisis par la production pour bien
illustrer le scénario centré sur la
justice esthétiquement
parlant ce centre de tour la place
jeanorè l'Hôtel de Ville et cetera ça a
quand même de la gueule ça un truc don
et ça a ce côté imposant ce qui fait que
quand on un peu de justice c'est assez
intéressant niveau
image au total l'équipe de tournage
reste en Touren une vingtaine de jours
mais on ignore encore la date de
diffusion une chose est sûre ce sera sur
France